james furlong a hérité d'un cadeau
un cadeau terrifiant qu'avez-vous fait
une malédiction
qui l'a conduit à
s'enfuir c'était avant qu'il ne la rencontre
je suis mae comment tu
t'appelles james
ce qui s'est passé ici ressemble à une
bombe nucléaire a explosé
tu peux t'asseoir à côté  moi si tu
veux tu t'es enfui
je ne vais nulle part jusqu'à ce que tu trouves ma
fille
ils ne peuvent plus opérer
désolé
ils ne devraient plus être là de
quoi as tu peur
personne ne peut être autour de moi les
gens meurent autour de moi tout mon
la vie
je ne suis pas en sécurité ici
parce que je ne peux pas l'arrêter
je sais que ça va me tuer james ce n'est
pas toi
tu ne vas blesser personne
pas tant que tu es avec moi
donc tout s'équilibre
je ne pourrais jamais l'arrêter
J'aurais dû partir il y a longtemps oui
je n'ai pas peur de toi
reste avec moi